前面講了不少外資跟投信的想法
那今天小哥來自然要告訴我們
業內主力這波有受傷喔
那急著談上來也會想要趕快來回血
還有處置股的調整
大家都知道以前小哥喜歡處置股
現在20分鐘沒了
只能2分鐘那要做什麼呢
接下來請要哥了
現在只剩2分鐘
只剩2分鐘可以玩
太短了
對啊
可是你喜歡短啊
我喜歡短
不過這個說好
其實周轉力變快了
是
因為平常還要等20分鐘
以前我們玩處置
這個盤中呢
都有時間去上個廁所
是
現在都要包尿布
好
等一下也會順帶來分享
因為最近有一些公司被關
但是兩分鐘我們怎麼判斷
全聯昨天
法說明明財報一季118塊的EPS
結果今天直接送他9%的下跌
那大力光今天也是回檔
可是你覺得他籌碼是不錯的
等一下幫我們看全正大戶
好 首先我們先來看這個群聯
怎麼了啦
那群聯其實我覺得最重要的問題
就是在這裡
是
第三季這個內的漲幅
數以到一到兩成
毛利率將降至56.7%
那這個前面都很好
但是股市是看未來的
對
那第二季呢
他的毛利率很高 65.3
上半年又有63.8
但是第三季會下降
這個很多
像一些眷商
然後就富邦
直接下修
直接下修啦
其實未來還是比較重要
好 這是就是市場殘忍的地方
賺了這麼多錢
因為其實潘董有講一件事
毛利率在高上去
全市場都會受不了
這個是事實
可是對他們自己不利
對啊 因為他聽完這句話
富邦就下修他了
對
所以這邊股市一樣
這個之前的成績再怎麼好
未來的有點擔心就會下修
那尤其其實他們這波上來也漲很多的
漲蠻多的股價就比較容易修正一下
好 那我們先來看大立光
CPU的代表
對 大立光絕對是CPU台積電力挺
9月份要部件手條是動畫式
這個是產線 所以看起來是蠻有未來的
那昨天秒田席今天有稍微修正一點
那我對大立光未來的看法還是蠻樂觀的
我們就來看一下一個代表記憶體
一個代表CPO
對 好 那這個
來看一下 群練
那群練呢各位看到
他這陣子從低點上來
是有反彈的
其實也反彈蠻多的
對 也反彈了
像這種從下通道的反彈
來到上通道
通常會有點壓力
是
對對對
因為這個是統計學上的壓力
是
因為它這個布林通道
還算這個平
所以本來就預壓了
對 本來就預壓了
那預壓了剛好又遇到這個事件
所以修正一下我覺得OK的
是
那大立光在這位置
他在
他跟群年一樣
有點在這個上通道的位置
是
不過對群年而言
因為貸寬太寬了
所以他壓力比較大
好 這邊也要幫大家解釋
因為貸寬寬
他可能就會變成來回正
可是大立光待關仔
他就有機會稍微窄一點
比較能力突破
但這個稍微窄
跟一般股票比起來也很寬
也很寬
也到30幾%
這群人比較誇張
最近他的籌碼也稍微變好一點
投信最近是不離不棄
是喜歡他的
買蠻多的
所以大立光我看起來
只要他有拉回修正
都是不錯買一點
兩檔比起來
可能大立光回檔
也會比較勇敢
是比較勇敢一點
接下來看這些族群
南亞 南電 聯貿 台光電
稍微排講這樣的原因
是同一個族群就是同伯類
因為南亞今天有宣布
他的同伯類的材料
要再漲價兩成
所以南電這個載板
然後聯貿 台光電是CCL
台光電很猛
接近625年的歷史新高了
而且他前波碟的時候
他不算碟太深
他這個前波從高檔跌下來
大概跌30幾%而已
當然不算跌太深
6字頭 好歹算3字頭
其實30幾%真的算跌少的
因為像被動都跌70%
可是他是大龍頭
那這波反彈過來
蠻厲害的 其實離前高不遠
不遠不遠
所以這個臺光電
這個即便前波主力有災脈
反正最近這個籌碼相對安定
一下子就漲回來
好猛 他盤中差50塊而已
差50塊而已
所以其實創高是有機會的
那我們來看藍芽
藍芽也是一樣
從前波跌下來
那這波也反彈蠻多的
所以這些股票
藍芽也是一樣
他是強的 都強
這四檔都強
這四檔最強的是聯帽
這個不只過前高創高了
那而且他還怎麼樣
他被處置了
這聯貿連續兩次處置
這兩次處置都是兩分鐘
那這次的兩分鐘處置
這個新的措施
那新的措施
他只是把時間變短而已
但是整個該圈存的還是得圈存
所以我們這樣看起來統計上
他還是有賣壓
但是聯貿就非常厲害
即便遇到兩分鐘的再次處置
他看起來沒什麼賣壓
那像這種看起來沒什麼賣壓
他再漲下去
他有可能會處置不完
這次的處置不完是兩分兩分
會不會影響沒那麼大
一直都兩分鐘
那我覺得主力
對主力而言
因為其實再次處置了兩分鐘
他整個量還是會縮
因為你就是要圈存
你就是要先繳錢
才能買股票
所以這種我覺得短線上
他還是會有壓力下來
那這幾檔都是一樣的
都是從低檔反彈要靠近前高
那靠近錢高你就要特別留意
因為靠近錢高一定有之前的套老賣壓
所以說靠近錢高有套老賣壓
你不如等他拉回再買比較安全
是
但是籌碼上來看
這四檔都還是OK的
從來看都還是OK
這主力都買 聯貿買得最多
聯貿買最多
聯貿買最多 所以他最強
因為這些大家可以回頭去看
7月8號跟6月26號這兩機
都是籌碼好才推的
也安然的在這波股災中重新復活
重新復活
因為這種談起來已經快漸漸全高
算是很厲害的股票
你看最近被那種談那麼多
可是離全高還是很遠
還沒有
還是很遠
那我們從現在看
這個群聯法說變法會
是真的
那就導致這個基底
他今天的這個漲跌互限
不過比較多的是這個跌
跌比較多
那這個記憶體類果
其實他們前波都漲很多
去年記憶體漲最多
那記憶體漲最多也漲最早
漲最多漲最早的最先修正
那修正完之後也最早反彈
那最近記憶體也開始在彈了
南亞科有創高了嗎
也代表
那這些呢
他們的這個前半段
他的阻力從來都還不錯
大概切到胃肝嗎
跳跳胃肝
但是胃肝有點弱啊
對 餵鋼因為只剩10剩4
那這個餵鋼以上的充滿都不錯
餵鋼以下的充滿比較差一點
所以大家來看南亞科
大哥南亞科
創高了 而且有那支書報告是1000塊
但是呢
他這個創高
創高的充滿是蠻漂亮的
這個主力看起來是連買
但是這種連買呢
他也沒有說
這個買的很多
都買的時候會休息一下 買的時候休息一下
所以這種呢 他可能就慢慢慢慢
這鋸齒狀的慢慢長上去
所以這種還是一樣
今天是買黑不買紅
買黑不買紅
對 因為到了上通道呢
他的壓力比較多
買黑心情可能會比較安定一點
因為當你最高隔天又殺低了
哇 這個你可能又要想評審
好 但籌碼是好的
哦 說話不錯
好籌碼
每次買都大買
這調節一點點
是 好
所以南亞克是這麼看
好 所以有好的籌碼
我們就可以買黑不買紅
是的 好 來看下一個
下一個預創 我這太強了
因為剛剛哥還問我說
他到底是
我說因為他做什麼他都有
像今天長軍功
搞不好他也可以說他有
因為他以前有做過無人機
真的很厲害
那這個而且你看
他第一檔說要實庫長谷
一時事你看他在
這個不知道是消息是提早在怎樣
是前一天是跳空漲停
可能跟那個 跟當時的盤是有關
那後面呢 一時四晚
哇一路攻上去
一路攻上去呢
他也一直都有面臨處置的問題
可是面臨處置問題呢
他還繼續漲 對
非常厲害
那怎麼辦 現在單兵如何處置
你看他袋塊已經全部打開了
然後他也在往上攻
還在往上攻
但是我們來看一下
他的主力呢 因為處置的關係
主力呢 就沒有買像之前這麼多
這麼多
所以呢
這種處置下去
他也會連續處置
是
所以連續處置的股票
我們都是等他因為處置拉回
因為處置拉回那個點
會是一個很好的買點
現在看教科
他是創歷史新高的股票
教科也是一樣 他跟預算很像
是
他的主力也是聯買
但教科最近這個
黑K比較多
因為這個處置關係
買盤有點不計
是
所以也是一樣
只要他有回檔
都是很好的買點
一樣也是讓子回頭
因為他們月線應該都上揚的
是 叫我這個也可以留意
來看下一個 華方店
那華方店他的籌碼就比較差
為什麼這樣
那我們來看
華方店的主力是沿途一路賣的
所以他跟南亞克比起來
就相對弱比較多
他都沒有創高
奇怪 兩家本來一起放在一起比的
這次怎麼差距拉得那麼遠
我覺得是籌碼的關係
那一到這個位置
這位是布林通道的平行上通道
對
到平行上通道本來就有壓力
然後他主力呈現賣超市
他壓力更大
是
所以華邦店這種股票
只要來到上通道
我都建議你
這個有獲利的趕快先賣一些
好
雖然剛剛看到預創金
還有個比較右上角
但他比較符合浪子回頭
華邦店看起來比較沒有賬
可惜衝罵也不好
也不好
像這種平行上通道
大概就得也賣了
是
好
這個接下來看這個CPO
因為有一堆被關緊閉
華興光聯軍這個訊息
他們很猛耶 之前先疊
現在這是先長 又長到都被關
對啊 前陣子有的是疊很多被關
現在是長很多被關
那這幾個看起來
前面的籌碼看起來還不錯
那今天的疊幅都還蠻大的
都還蠻大的
我們來看這個華興光
好 滑星光
那滑星光你看
前波這樣子疊很深
對
疊很深到這個瓶上下通道之後
這邊開始起漲
是
這邊是疊得有點多
後面進處置
是
然後最近又漲多進處置
所以這種漲多進處置
他最近有一個
浪子回頭的機會
也是浪子回頭
對
所以下禮拜
這滑星光腳有機會
浪子回頭
各位可以考慮一下買點
好
而且投信蠻喜歡他的
最近投信有買
投信大買
對 心滿喜歡
現在看下一個 聯軍
聯軍也一樣
聯軍也是處置
這個處置
只要有回檔
不過這種平行通道的回檔
下通道會是一個很好的買點
要到下通道
對 下通道
好
接下來我們看這個
台新科
混入了一檔
其實算封測
但是應該有做到CPU相關
台新科大概從晚比較好一點
所以這個
最近一樣
這是一個平行的通道
是 平時通道下通道是比較適合買
那上通道你看 只要一到上通道就有壓力
所以上通道你可以考慮賣掉一些
做一個盤整區間操作
好 會比較好
封測業績都是好的
雖然混在CPU裡面
但是只要以封測來說
EPS根本都是相對好的
好 那最後我們來看這個波段權證
在做什麼呢
那波段權證最近
他的名單沒有大幅的更新
最近這個有波段我們還持續追蹤的
那比較好的籌碼是寶瑞跟松川金秘
還有新的這三個是比較好的
但是好像沒有很強力
寶瑞倒是給的蠻強力
可是寶瑞的股價
股價就一直跑到這邊
你看慣例你家還付的
不如說要花要
寶瑞真的好辛苦
真的
好那我們來看另外兩檔
所以一定放過寶瑞
先來看松川金秘
來看松川金秘
上次在這邊講之後有漲一波
然後後來遇到了7月份的大盤大修正
整個跌下來
這講完之後其實還漲蠻多的
但7月份大修正他也跟著修正
不過最近又快創新高了
所以這個酸精明各位也可以留意一下
那最後看這個星雲
設備類股
星雲是南藤哥
南藤哥高檔也買 高檔買
然後薩蒂大福的加碼
所以未來看起來也是有機會
好他這個有可能前面已經自動歸零嗎
還沒有 還沒有
還沒有到歸零
好 設備股也是業績非常有保障的
這邊非常謝謝小哥 謝謝
還記得上市小哥來
是幫我們分享地板股
沒想到短短的兩週之後呢
他已經變成主力在找機會要上車了
因為有一些股票有一些族群
例如像ABF Japan
雖然很好可是主力會覺得到這邊
要再買的話有點吃力
會產生一個所謂的類股輪動
像剛剛講的不管 CPO 或是記憶體
或是不斷權政大戶等等的
他們會去找還有肉的
所以現階段
觀察籌碼變得非常重要
因為統一族群
可能籌碼會兩極化
主力也急著想在這一波回來上車
所以我們散問朋友看清楚就好囉
今天是星期五的晚上
非常謝謝三位的朋友來到現場
這個禮拜是一個反彈週
也會讓不少人可能產生了一點點
FORMOR的情緒但不用
我們有發現
頭線也在回補
主力打火也在找標的
大家都是在一個水平線上面
各評本是
為我們參考這些資訊的話
下個禮拜的佈局方向
其實就很清楚
也希望今天的理財展秀
對您投資有幫助
下週再會囉
拜拜